well what attracted you to Vinnie you
know what it wasn't that he thinks it is
it's not it wasn't his eyes he always
says it's the eyes it's not the eyes
that wasn't no but he loves saying that
it's the eyes it wasn't the eyes what
was it um I don't know initially so we
met on Instagram who slid in the who DM
he did but I kind of initiated it I'll
admit that what did he say no no no no
he said he she was she
okay I I going to tell the truth um he
popped up on my Explorer page and I
don't follow like a lot of stunt things
or a lot of stuff like that but I just
saw like this guy back flipping into
fire and I was like oh that's cool so I
clicked on it and I saw he had tattoos
it was the tattoos first that's what it
was first like oh he's got a lot of
tattoos um and then I don't know I was
just looking on I was just creeping and
it was more just like your personality I
was like oh he's like really funny I
just I I felt like you were very
transparent that's what it was um but
like physical it was your smile I really
liked your smile that's what the first
thing was it wasn't the eyes all right
wow it was the smile what can I say and
then you got then took you out on the
first date yeah where'd he take you uh I
forget the name it was in Malibu it
really nice this really good restaurant
in Malibu called Sunset were you
impressed I was impressed I was he
actually so um we talked on FaceTime for
a few weeks before we met cuz I was in
Canada um and then I had come up to LA
and the first 10 minutes of the C he
didn't say anything
he shy like he didn't speak I was
talking and talking and talking he was
like oh yeah yeah like we you're like a
completely different person a stalking I
was really shy he was so shy like
wouldn't even like look me in the eye
just so yeah it was really nice okay
yeah we I think
before you guys uh
started
dating we had discussed on the the
podcast that Vinnie like just to our
shock and surprise like has it's like
been really popular with like wildly
attractive women I saw it I saw it
that's almost what turned me off CU I
was like oh great he's like really out
there I was like she thought I was a
cheater yeah I thought not a cheater
yeah
noely player I thought you were a player
okay so
that
now I want to be I want to be a little
candid
here um I I I I haven't said anything a
resentment been harboring a resentment
towards Vinnie oh boy okay yeah because
when we had Knoxville on the podcast
first two minutes of the podcast I
explained to Knoxville that uh since the
last time he was on that I really put
effort into into cultivating better
convers ational etiquette not
interrupting people letting people speak
and and I said I think I've gotten I
think I've gotten better and Vinnie's up
there he
goes I'm like I'm like wait what like I
mean really I have been really trying I
think I've gotten really you have you've
gotten a little better not greatly
better not like really really better
he's doubling down wow it dude it made
for a good
riff and I'm just like oh God like that
that's the episode where we know every
single one of our vers and it's in the
first two minutes of the episode and
Vinnie's over here be like he do you
suck you suck your show sucks you suck
well I mean I think I think what the E
meant was like you gotten 80% better
yeah n and you're taking the E to mean
15% better all right I'd say 70% better
all right yeah I'd say 90 I mean we
don't need to go over report over here
okay you just cut me
off okay but but that's got nothing to
do with anything and uh had to steer
that towards
you when we're talking about Autumn and
Vinnie right I was joking around with
Isaac saying like oh man I want to let
Vinnie have it because I'm so mad about
the no thing I'm not mad and I don't
want to let you have it um but you
[Music]
[__] I I don't want to Dam I
didn't know you were a little upset
about that I mean I was just like let me
do I wasn't I didn't know either I
didn't I didn't think of anything of it
yeah I didn't either like there was a
lot of laughter after that yeah I mean
it was funny but it was a
burn okay okay but I will justify
anything that uh this is just going to
be juicy right here yeah okay when we
got to England yes when we landed in
England yes you were very quiet very
very withdrawn yes very sad yes because
you had received a a call or had a
conversation with Autumn yes where she
explained that your relationship was
over oh yeah I remember
that I was actually that popped in my
head the other day and I got really mad
about it and I was like I'm not going to
do that I just well what can let's hear
from Autumn what happened okay yeah sure
okay so I I'm someone when I start
dating someone I'm very transparent
about things that I like things I don't
like in relationships and you know I I
just air it all out cuz my thing is like
from that you can be like okay you know
I this isn't going to work for me I
don't want to be with you you know maybe
I have these habits or I do these things
so I just like to tell someone you know
um I like you know I like flowers and I
don't like when you like girls Instagram
pictures so I was very you know so he
did the flowers thing he always sent me
flowers he's very nice um but I did
notice from like the beginning of us
talking to like getting into dating I
would see his follower number go up a
lot and I was
like okay the people who he is following
his following yeah and it was always
like Instagram girls you know yeah like
like the fitness accounts with 12
million followers yeah and so as I
understood it Autumn you said to Vinnie
like hey it bothers me when you follow
porn stars and like their posts healthy
boundary yeah and then like and then it
it continues after you said that you had
a problem with that a a couple times it
continued a few more couple we just
heard it was once no it continued a few
times and it wasn't like he was like
messing like it wasn't anything like
that like you were not again you're not
like a cheater but he just kept doing it
like um so I got mad because I was like
I'm someone if I like initiate a
boundary like if someone tells me
they're not comfortable with something
then I'm like I won't do it I won't do
it right um so he kept doing doing it so
um on top of that he didn't like text me
right away when he got to London so that
made me mad too cuz I was like I know
you're there like you're not texting me
so in my head I was like oh he's
following all these girls he's like
whatever I was just spiraling so I was
like you know what like if that's
something you like to do if you like to
follow these accounts and consume it
that's fine but you're not going to do
it when you're with me I don't think it
was unfair I don't think it it was 100%
like the most rational healthy boundary
and and Vinnie was it wasn't like it
just came out of nowhere it was like
right you know if that was something
that I never discussed and then I just
broke up it's like okay well you never
express cuz some people don't care about
that in relationship you want to know
what he ate after you broke up with them
what
what I came down to the lobby and he's
eating the whole pizza and a [__]
gallon of ice cream I'm like Jesus
Christ dude what are you eating mind you
eight hours before that he's like I'm on
a diet I'm
like he he was absolutely devastated
like it was the the heart his thing and
all he had to say for himself was like
dude like all I did was like a photo he
did not just like a photo he followed
like half of the population of Instagram
models I was like yeah he he wasn't
defending himself he was just like he's
just like I can't help it like I see a
hot chick I I I hit follow double tap
like I can't it's just like you know
doesn't mean anything by it I just like
I just can't help it like I see it I
like
it that's that's what I get but like my
thing is too like I see how dudes on
Instagram all the time but in my brain
it's like as a girl point if I go and
look at who's following me I assume that
it's if it's a do the interest like you
see my Instagram I'm not posting like
pictures of me at the library so if
you're following me then you know that's
obviously what so to me it's like if
someone's in a relationship if you see
someone that's attractive cool she's
attractive just keep swiping okay but
are dudes dming you yeah are you
responding um no I haven't there was
this um I always tell you like there's
this one guy that was in a band and I
was like like I he dm' me like this is
so cool so I like responded I'm like oh
thanks like yeah I love your music and
then he said oh send me a text sometime
and I never answered but I I tell him
everything I always tell him I'm like I
feel like I tell you too much cuz
sometimes I go into detail and I don't
want to know but it's just my conscience
like I if I'm something pops in my head
or something happens I'm like I need to
tell you you gotta behave at all times
as though your significant other is
watching on like a special surveillance
camera so that everything you do is
always like respectful of your
significant yeah Isaac brought up Jeremy
Rogers cuz he was one of the dudes that
was hitting her up oh wow wow I never I
never answered him
didn't who who was the guy in the band
can you say um can you just say the name
of the band can I say that well he's not
he's like a solo musician I don't know
if I can I don't
can just start foll okay I'm so excited
about that we don't we don't need to
worry about that um but um he's been
better since then oh yeah yeah I think
that was like the wakeup call of me
being like this is actually boundary
like this is actually ticking me off
like we you're not Breer yeah do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
Plus steo butthole destroyer and steo
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude